Phasing is a way to simulate a construction schedule.
You organize phases on a timeline calendar and then hide or unhide components as needed for each phase.
Open the file named For Phasing that's been provided to you.
Go to the Media Phasing Group panel.
Note that there's already a media file defined. We'll look at it, although you'll be creating your own in a second.
Click the Phasing 1 thumbnail to open the timeline for it.
If you want, you can click the Zoom Out tool to view the extents of the phases, 9 phases that take about a year of construction work.
If you scrub through the timeline, you can see the work evolving, from the main excavations all the way to fully constructed and inhabited projects.
Exit Media mode. Let's look at how we can set this up.
First thing you need to do is to define phasing content in the scene graph and scene graph containers.
Here it's already been done for you. Hide all the phase containers to effectively hide your project.
Unhide them one at a time to see their content, and you'll have an idea how they were sorted.
Go to the Phasing panel and create a new phasing calendar.
With the clip selected, make sure the container named Phase 1 is displayed in the scene graph and all other phase containers hidden.
This represents the start of the work, the excavation work.
Click Create Phase again to add a second clip.
Unhide Phases 2 and 3 and hide Phase 1. Excavation is done and we have the foundations in place.
Click Create Phase again to add a third clip.
This time, hide Phase 2, the workers and their equipment, and unhide Phase 4 as the walls start coming up.
If you make a mistake, you can select the clip on the timeline and review what needs to be visible or hidden.
Keep on going but make sure you select the last clip on the timeline before proceeding.
Add other clips and adjust the visibility of containers accordingly.
At any time, you can scrub through the timeline to check your work.
This is easy enough, but how do you output an animation of this phasing work?
This is done by going to the Media video panel.
Earlier, we used the video tool to keyframe camera motion but here, we just set it up to read the phasing calendar we defined.
Create a new video and set it to about 30 seconds in length as before.
Go back one step and rename the video Mic Phasing but more importantly, expand the Details sub-panel and set the Phasing group to the new phasing definition you just created.
That's it. From this point on, you simply need to output that video to disk as you have already learned.
This marks the end of this class. I hope you have enjoyed it.